please welcome eric stone street
[Applause]
we have a lovely view what a wonderful
view thank you
that's now like the 15th time i've seen
that clip from domino masters
and i have to ask
it looks so fun
has there been a moment where somebody
accidentally
like
set it off
when it wasn't like did someone screw up
a hundred percent no
a hundred percent people are out there
like literally with tweezers putting
dominoes in spots and there are
accidents and mistakes and it all like
five hours of work is just gone
yeah yes do people like scream and swear
yes spit and like yes flip out i would
turn into linda blair and the exorcist i
would pee soon it was all me it was me
up there going how much longer do we
have to be here now like it was it was
it was crazy i think i have like anxiety
just knowing i would be the guy oh yeah
that was like hip check the table that
was near one of the dominoes and then
the whole thing like and i'd be standing
there
like the classic idiot in the 1980s
comedy like
well i'm gonna give you another thing
for your anxiety tonight oh please bring
it on shot at the santa monica airport
oh no okay
where airplanes are landing over the
hangar and then i'm sorry hello have you
heard of earthquakes so we would go home
at night there'd be cameras rolling 24
hours a day on the on the stages
and hope that an earthquake didn't
happen and knocked the dominoes over oh
my god
all things i didn't think of before i
said yes to doing the show
i love that you know you're from kansas
kansas city yes and um
that you know
you grew up on a farm
and what was that life like because it
pays off i think with with cam for me
yeah well i i grew up i wanted a job
when i was a kid just like other kids
kind of like think to their parents what
was your dream when you were a kid well
i wanted when i was a young kid i wanted
to be a clown in the circus which i got
to be a clown in the greatest circus of
all hollywood right
and then i wanted to be a prison
administrator at some point
what happened that sparked that interest
because in kansas city where i grew up
there are prisons it's known for
leavenworth the federal disciplinary
barracks for the army so i saw them as a
kid and i was always intrigued my dad
was like but you're not going in one so
i went to college and i wasn't a big fan
of going to college but
i found something that was interesting
which was sociology and then that led me
to wanting to be work in the
correctional system the they call it the
penal system don't laugh but that's
drew
pino beetle
so
i did a play in college and that
redirected my my life which i'm so
thankful for well i love
when
you speak about
where you grew up and sort of having
this mindset
of bringing your character cam on modern
family
you know
into people's hearts and minds
can you tell me about that i wanted
cameron to be someone that everyone
would want to sit down and have a beer
with yeah right and the writers and the
creators of the show were very
interested in my background the clowning
the drumming the farming the footballing
all that stuff they wanted to bring that
to the character to make cameron a very
well-rounded even though people look at
some might look at it and say well
that's a stereotype cameron is the
opposite of uh
true to your life right and it's all
real things that you know i wanted
cameron to be defined by something other
than the fact that he was a gay man i
wanted him to be defined by that he was
a dad i wanted him to be defined by that
he was a parent or a a partner turned
out to be a husband i wanted him to be
defined by that he was a football coach
and that the fact that he was a gay man
that mitchell and cam are gay men is
just part of who they are not
who they are right
i i love that
[Music]
you